the movie is set in an alternate world
where black people have taken up all the
liberties they are considered the
superior race while the whites are
frowned upon and are given menial jobs
the blacks are responsible for much of
the scientific discoveries the majority
of the country's economy and their
contribution in the field of music
cinema and art on the contrary the
whites are regarded as problem-causing
people who are involved in illicit
dealings violence and other serious
crimes the movie opens up with a group
of black people enjoying dinner at a
wealthy businessman thaddeus thomas's
house while having dinner thaddeus talks
about the white people with his business
partners and mentions that they are
genetically inferior to them and deserve
to be deprived of a good quality of life
the scene then shifts to a white candy
factory where we are introduced to the
main character and a laborious worker
pinnock after completing the working
hours to be in the good books of the
black seniors pinhock accepts the task
of delivering a package to thaddeus's
residence on the way he comes across a
rich neighborhood which consists of
exclusively black people moments later
pennock arrives at the entrance of
thaddeus's residence and is allowed to
enter by a white female servant trying
to deliver the package thaddeus climbs
up the stairs and stands in front of the
house while waiting for someone to
receive the package panock starts
looking around the big mansion
surprisingly he notices thaddeus's wife
megan at the window
naked thaddeus who is speaking over a
phone catches pinnock peeping at his
wife and becomes enraged after
delivering the package pinnock drives to
his house and on the way notices some
white people being bullied by the black
police officers later he arrives home
and makes a failed attempt to try and
stop his rude neighbors from making loud
noise while partying pennock then enters
his house where he is greeted by his
little son donny following this
pinnock's wife marsha also arrives there
with their little daughter and welcomes
him home together they prepare dinner
and pinnock promises that he will get a
promotion soon so that they can shift to
a better neighborhood on the other hand
there is a gathering at thaddeus's house
once the discussion is over thaddeus
stops the vp of the candy factory lionel
and suggests he sends someone else other
than the peeping guy to deliver his
package the next time the following day
after finding that the foreman's
position at the factory is vacant panock
visits lionel's office and requests that
he promote him lionel takes his request
casually and tells him that he will look
into it seeing his careless attitude
pinnock reminds him of the extra shift
that he has been putting up lately he
also mentions about the delivery that he
conducted at thaddeus's house the day
before as soon as lionel hears this he
asks pinnock to take a seat and politely
informs him that he can no longer
continue working at the factory pinnock
is shocked to hear this and tells lionel
that he cannot fire him without any
reason lionel however tries to make
pinnock understand that the decision
will be good for him in the long run
when pennock insists on knowing the
reason vinyl reveals that the owner of
the factory thaddeus noticed him peeping
at his wife when he went there to
deliver the package in the next scene
pinnock can be seen standing outside
thaddeus's house ready to peep again
requesting the white servant let him
talk with thaddeus and clear the
misunderstanding the servant lady walks
up to thaddeus and informs him about the
situation but as he is in a meeting he
refuses to talk as a result pinnock is
ignored at the entrance despite begging
for over an hour devastated pinnock
visits the employment office to find a
new job but all he can get is low-paying
work which won't be sufficient to
support his family later as he drives
toward his home exhausted his car breaks
down in the middle of the road and he is
forced to walk just then some police
officers arrive and ask him to put his
hands behind his head they force him
down and ask him to show his id as his
appearance matches with a high-profile
robber as the commotion goes on some
white people gather around the place and
demand the officers leave pinnock alone
soon they start throwing wine bottles at
the police and as a result they get
enraged and beat up pinnock before
driving away following this pinnock
arrives home injured and marsha is
shocked to see him in this condition
panock briefs her about the injustice he
just suffered and in turn marsha informs
him that the landlord has threatened
them to evacuate the house if they fail
to pay their rent soon one early morning
the pinnock family is woken up by the
landlord who has arrived there with a
couple of police officers the officers
informed pinnock that they're here to
request them to evacuate the place with
their belongings immediately after the
pinnock family gathered their important
belongings pinnock's mother-in-law
chastises him for being a bad husband
and informs him that there is no room
for him at her house leaving him alone
the mother-in-law drives away with
marsha and the kids having nowhere to go
pinnock can be seen waiting for thaddeus
outside his entrance gate a while later
thaddeus arrives and asks pinnock what
he is doing realizing that the old man
doesn't recognize him pinnock takes out
a revolver and points it at thaddeus he
then enters thadius's car and tells him
that they need to talk pinnock hands him
a piece of paper and asks him to provide
him with the amount of money written
there thaddeus tries to escape claiming
that he doesn't have that kind of cash
on him but pinock forces him to drive to
a nearby bank moments later the duo
arrives outside a bank and pinnock
threatens thaddeus to talk to the teller
standing at the window following the
order thaddeus tries to converse with
the white teller and ask for some money
but the teller refuses to help him
mentioning that the bank is closed for
the day this enrages thaddeus and he
threatens the teller to call his
superior but before things can escalate
pinock forces thaddeus to drive away
following this they drive to a jungle
and stop near penox truck after
exchanging cars they once again resume
their journey but this time pinnock
takes the steering wheel while thaddeus
is ordered to stay still after some time
inside the car the duo arrives outside
pinnock's neighborhood where he used to
live here pinnock mentions that his
neighborhood is better than thadius's
area he also blames thaddeus for his
present miserable condition surprisingly
thaddeus is oblivious to what pinnock is
saying and asks for an explanation
hearing this pinnock laughs and tells
thaddeus that he is the one who came to
deliver the package some days before
pinnock then accuses thadius of giving
orders to lionel to fire him thaddeus
immediately refuses the accusation
mentioning that he only told lionel to
hire a new delivery guy he then offers
to settle the matter over a call with
lionel however pinock refuses the offer
and decides to wait until monday when
the banks are open in the next scene
pinnock takes thaddeus to a local
restaurant and buys some food there at
the same time some white boys arrive and
start cursing loudly the restaurant
owner tries to send them away but the
boys refuse to move later when the boys
stare at thaddeus pinhock suggests that
they leave the place as they are walking
out of the restaurant the white boys
block their way and capture them pinak
tries to take out his gun but one of the
boys hits him throwing away his gun
hearing the commotion the elderly
restaurant owner walks outside holding a
rifle and shoots at one of the white
boys killing him instantly seeing this
the boys become terrified and flee the
place meanwhile pinnock picks up his gun
and prepares to leave but thaddeus who
is still in shock at what he just saw
keeps on staring at the corpse following
this pinnock takes thaddeus to an
abandoned building and asks an old man
stanley to let them stay for the night
at first stanley refuses claiming that
he is scared of black men but when
pinnock fires his gun in the air stanley
realizes he's afraid of all men and he
reluctantly agrees the next day pinnock
again takes thaddeus to the nearby local
restaurant for dinner there thaddeus
asks pinak to let him make a phone call
and inform his family that he is all
right he also tells pinnock that he will
fulfill his demands and requests that he
let him go however pinnock tells him
that he cannot release him as he doubts
that he will inform the police moments
later when pinnock goes to the counter
to refill his soda cop thaddeus runs
away prompting pennock to chase him in
the next scene thaddeus deceives pinnock
by entering one of the roadside house
premises after he realizes that pinac
has run past the house he walks up to
the house's door and knocks on it a
couple of times when no one opens the
door for a while thaddeus breaks the
door glass and gets inside there he
finds a telephone and immediately calls
his wife megan he tells her to call the
cops but when megan asks about his
location he is clueless suddenly a white
girl walks up to him and recognizes him
as a robber she calls her father
informing him that someone is broken
into their house thaddeus tries his best
to make the girl understand that he is
not a robber but the girl picks up a gun
and points it at him in no time her
father arrives and sensing the danger
thaddeus throws a box at his head
injuring him seeing this the little girl
shoots at thaddeus but misses by an inch
causing the perpetrator to run away
meanwhile pinnock hears the gunshot and
rushes towards the house when he arrives
there the father informs him that a
black guy broke into their house and has
escaped following the direction provided
by the father pinnock finally spots
thaddeus after a bit of chasing pinnock
successfully manages to catch thadius
and bring him to the abandoned building
on their way thaddeus tells pinnock that
rather than complaining about his lost
job he should move on with his life and
try to find a new job instead he accuses
pinnock of failing to accept the
circumstances and trying to get away
with it unfortunately this further
enrages pinhock and he is compelled to
tape up thaddeus's hands and tie him
around a wooden pole this time he also
wraps a thick piece of cloth around
thaddeus's mouth so that he does not
speak on the other hand the police
arrive at the broken house and start
searching for thaddeus around the area
at the same time stanley arrives and
informs pinnock to run away from the
building as the cops are looking for him
everywhere he also suggests pinnock let
thaddeus go as he is not injured and the
police might reduce his sentence for
this despite this pinnock is adamant on
waiting until monday and refuses to
relinquish thaddeus just then when he
takes a look at thaddeus he finds him
gagging and coughing afraid pinnock
approaches thaddeus and opens his taping
and the cloth wrapped around his mouth
unfortunately thaddeus is already
unconscious by this time seeing this
stanley starts packing up his clothes
and prepares to leave however pinnock
cannot leave thaddeus in this condition
so he presses his chest to revive him
after a couple of attempts thaddeus
finally starts breathing despite
everything that they have been through
pinnock tells stanley that they should
take thaddeus to the hospital moments
later thaddeus can be seen inside
pinnock's truck on route to the hospital
sadly the truck breaks down desperate to
help thaddeus pinnock gets out of his
truck and asks her to lift with other
people one lady offers to help them but
when she notices a black man being
dragged out of pinnock's car she drives
away with no sign of any vehicles
driving around and seeing thaddeus's
miserable condition pinnock takes out
his gun and fires some shots into the
air he also shoots at some nearby stores
and breaks the glass starting an
emergency siren everywhere moments later
stanley notices a police car approaching
and suggests that pinnock leave the
place pinnock tries but after looking at
thadius's miserable condition he changes
his mind and decides to stay with him
until he is taken to the hospital
stanley tries to convince pinnock again
but the latter refuses and he is forced
to escape alone following this the
police officers arrive and ask pinnock
to put his hands behind his head
unfortunately they notice a gun in
pinhock's hand and without questioning
him they shoot him to death thaddeus is
looking at all this but he can do
nothing to stop the officers he feels
sad for pinnock and starts crying in the
final scene of the movie thaddeus visits
pinnock's mother-in-law's house and
meets with marsha he tries to introduce
himself but marsha tells him that
stanley has already told her everything
about the incident hearing this thaddeus
offers an envelope full of money
mentioning that it is for her family
however marsha refuses to accept the
money and returns it she then closes the
door on his face and heads inside the
movie ends as little donny stares at
thaddeus while he drives away in the car
sorry for not making jokes in this video
it just didn't feel funny to me
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications and leave a like to
help the channel out thank you for
watching